documentaries China's spotlight on the
world around us and in the case of the
best documentary Short subject that long
shines for only a short period of time
much like a Moonbeam or a shooting star
or a flicker of a candle or
and the nominees here are the barber of
Berlin
foot soldier of the civil rights
movement Robin Friday and gal dojin god
is the bigger Elvis
Rebecca camisa and Julian's incident in
New Baghdad James Brown a saving face
Daniel young he and sharmeen obaid
Jinora the tsunami and the cherry
blossom Lucy Walker and Kyra Carstensen
and the Oscar goes to saving face Daniel
young and sharmeen obaid Chinoy
this is the first Academy Award for
Daniel yummy and sharmeen obaid Chinoy
shamino vaccine I grew up in Pakistan
Daniel young was born and raised in
Wyoming they say that the hardest part
of his film was trying to stay
emotionally detached from what was
happening on the other side of the
camera look it's more important that the
Pakistani on the stage speak instead of
me but I just quickly want to simply
thank HBO Sheila Nevins Lisa held her
for making this film possible my wife
Erin and our editor Davis but please
PLEASE sharmeen speak
I just Daniel I want to dedicate this
award to all the heroes working on the
ground in Pakistan including dr.
Mohammad Javad who's here with us today
the plastic surgeon working on
rehabilitating all these women Ruksana
and Zakia who are our main subjects of
the film whose resilience in bravery in
the face of such adversity is admire and
to all the women in Pakistan who are
working for change don't give up on your
dreams this is for you